PHILIPPE KAUFFMANN:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Can you roll the video please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- There are multiple sides
of Schwab's business.
And one of those sides
is the advisor side
or the institutional side.
And obviously, we offer a lot of
products and a lot of services
to our institutional customers.
I'm responsible for making
sure that we deliver on behalf
of what our clients need.
As we were looking
for solutions,
bringing about a
device to the branches
where, again, clients could
very easily open up an account,
we reached out to our
colleagues over at Google.
And we asked them whether
or not Google's Chromebook
was something that would
be applicable to what
we were trying to solve.
That was on a Friday.
On Monday morning, we had two
of their top engineers engaged
with my engineers here.
3 and 1/2 hours later, I
get a knock on my door.
And I'll never forget
what they said to me.
They said, we've solved it.
Google offered a number of
services and capabilities
within their Chromebook
platform that
were incredibly attractive.
One of them was the ability to
remotely control the devices.
We could force them onto a
specific network, our network.
If they fell off that network,
they would be unusable.
If someone stole them,
we had the ability
to remotely wipe them.
I would say, one of the unique
features of the Chromebook
has to do with their
operating system.
The device isn't burdened
with a lot of legacy
or with a large OS.
Instead, the experience is,
you open the Chromebook.
And 10 seconds
later, you're online.
Because of the kiosk capability
that the Chromebook had
to offer, when
one of our clients
came in to open
up a SIP account,
we'd start up a new session.
And as soon as that Chromebook
was closed, session gone.
Everything gets erased.
The full rollout and development
started with a number
of weeks of user engagement.
We would take the Chromebooks
out to specific branches,
test it out.
And then, from there,
it was making sure
that the device could stand up
and do exactly what we needed
it to do, but do it at scale.
When you're working with a firm
that's got hundreds of branches
out there and you're going
to eventually deploy well
over 1,000 of these
devices, the ability
to control them from
a central location
is absolutely paramount.
And really, the Chromebook was
the one that met our needs.
They work at any
time, all the time.
[END PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
If we can switch to
the demo, please.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Can we switch the demo?
If we can switch back
to the slides, please.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
NADIA PEREZ: Merci, Philippe.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Can we switch to
the video, please?
Thanks.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The world is a
fast-moving place,
with lives lived on mobile.
It's not just a
phone in our pockets.
Mobile devices can
transform the way
we work, providing powerful
tools for every business,
tools that connect you to
the power of the cloud,
tools that make
you more efficient,
tools that you
can take anywhere,
tools that are purpose-built
for your business and customers,
tools that work for
you, from the storefront
to the warehouse.
Android is the world's
choice for mobile.
It's easy, robust, and
designed to be used by anyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No matter what industry, Android
provides enhanced security
to keep your data safe.
It's designed to be
innovative yet reliable,
to help your people
work smarter and faster.
After all, with great
tools, come great results.
Android-- powering the
world's work devices.
[END PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
--Zero Touch Deployment.
Zero Touch-- [SPEAKING FRENCH]
Application management--
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
--Zero Touch.
Zero Touch-- [SPEAKING FRENCH]
Can we switch to
the device, please?
[SPEAKING FRENCH]